>> Tucker: LAST NIGHT JOE BIDEN
PROMISED TO REVERSE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION’S FOREIGN POLICY
ON THE QUESTION OF CHINA.
ACCORDING THE BIDEN, THE U.S.
WILL FOLLOW SOMETHING CALLED THE
INTERNATIONAL RULES OF THE ROAD.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN EXACTLY?
YOU CAN GUESS WHAT IT MEANS.
MORE SUBSERVIENCE TO CHINA.
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR HERE.
THE PIECE IS CALLED "THE 30
PIECES OF TYRANTS."
IT’S A TRUE BOOK.
WE THANK YOU FOR COMING IN ON
AND FOR THE MENTAL ENERGY
REQUIRED TO CONNECT ALL THE
DOTS.
I HOPE OUR READERS READ IT FOR
THEMSELVES.
BUT YOU SUMMARIZE YOUR POSITION.
>> BASICALLY WHAT I WANTED TO
EXPLAIN IS WHY SO MANY THINGS
LOOK CRAZY, MANY THINGS THAT YOU
COVER ON YOUR SHOW ALL THE TIME.
WHY PEOPLE ARE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER IN SUCH PROFOUND NUMBERS.
IT ALL LOOKS CRAZY UNTIL YOU
REALIZE THERE’S A REASON IT’S
GOING ON.
THE REASON IS BECAUSE THE
OLIGARCHY THAT RUNS THIS COUNTRY
NOW IS NOT PRIMARILY LOYAL TO
THE UNITED STATES.
THEY DO NOT CARE ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF DAMAGE THAT THEY DO TO
AMERICA, THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT
THE DAMAGE THAT THEY DO TO
AMERICANS.
THAT’S PART OF THE SYSTEM.
THE PRIMARY LOYALTY IS TO THEIR
RELATIONSHIP TO THE COMMUNIST
CHINESE PARTY THAT IS THEIR
CENTER OF GRAVITY, THE SORT OF
THEIR WEALTH, PRIVILEGE AND
PRESTIGE.
>> Tucker: SO KEEP CONNECTING,
IF YOU WILL.
I HOPE THAT, AGAIN, PEOPLE WILL
READ THIS BECAUSE PRINT IS THE
ONLY MEDIUM THAT CAN FULLY
EXPLAIN THE THESIS AS COMPLEX AS
YOURS.
WHAT ELSE WOULD CONNECT TO THAT
POINT?
>> THE BIG THING IS STARTING --
ONE OF THE KEY DATES -- IT
STARTS WITH HENRY KISSINGERS AND
NICK SON’S OPENING OF CHINA.
IN 1994, BILL CLINTON DECIDED TO
DELINK HUMAN RIGHTS AND TRADE.
HE SAID WE WERE HOPEFUL THAT
CHINA WOULD ADOPT MORE
DEMOCRATIC POLICIES.
IT WAS NONSENSE.
THE PREMIER OF CHINA AT THE
TIME, THIS IS THE MAN THAT
CATAPULTED TO POWER AFTER
SENDING TANKS INTO TIANANMEN
SQUARE.
THE AMERICAN ELITE KNEW WHAT
THEY WERE GETTING INTO.
THEY LOOKED AT AN ENORMOUS
CHEAP, LABOR POOL AND THEY SAID
WE’RE GOING TO GET RICH.
THAT’S WHAT HAPPENED.
WE ARE MORE THAN A QUARTER OF A
CENTURY ALONG AND THAT’S WHAT
HAS HAPPENED.
ONE OF THE INTERESTING THINGS
THAT HAPPENED DURING THE DONALD
TRUMP PRESIDENCY BECAUSE DONALD
TRUMP STARTED CALLING THESE
PEOPLE OUT.
I THINK THAT DONALD TRUMP DIDN’T
EVEN HAVE THAT CLEAR SENSE OF
HOW TIED IN, HOW EXTENSIVE THIS
NETWORK WAS.
ONE OF THE EXAMPLES THAT I
MENTIONED, WHOEVER WOULD HAVE
PUT APPLE CEO TIM COOK AND
LEBRON JAMES IN THE SAME FAMILY
ALBUM?
THERE THEY ARE.
THEIR WEALTH RELIES ON THE TWO
SAME THINGS.
CHEAP CHINESE LABOR AND A
GROWING CHINESE CONSUMER MARKET.
IF YOU LOOK ACROSS, THIS IS NOT
JUST ENTERTAINMENT.
IT’S NOT JUST TECH.
IT GOES IN TO THE CORPORATE
WORLD, GOES INTO FINANCE.
UNFORTUNATELY IT AFFECTS OUR
GOVERNMENT THROUGHOUT.
ONE OF THE MOST ASTONISHING
REVELATIONS THAT JOHN RATCLIFFE
WROTE REGARDING THE CIA.
CIA MANAGEMENT WAS BULLYING
ANALYSTS SAYING THEY DIDN’T LIKE
THEIR ANALYSIS OF CHINA BECAUSE
THEY WERE WORRIED ABOUT THE
POLICIES IT MIGHT ENCOURAGE,
MEANING TRUMP’S POLICIES ON
CHINA.
HE WAS HARD ON CHINA.
CIA MANAGEMENT WAS PROTECTING
CHINA FROM SOLID ANALYSIS.
IT’S ASTONISHING.
BUT TAKE IT A STEP FURTHER.
REMEMBER WHO OWNS THE CLOUD ON
WHICH ALL OF THE CIA’S
INFORMATION IS COLLECTED.
THAT IS JEFF BEZOS WHO IS
CHINA’S NUMBER 1 DISTRIBUTOR IN
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: IN 10 SECONDS, DOES
IT SHOCK YOU THE NEW DEFENSE
SECRETARY HAS BASICALLY SAID THE
GREATEST THREAT IS NOT CHINA BUT
WHITE SUPREMACY?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
LOOK AT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
AND THE FIRST FAMILY, YOU CAN
SEE THERE’S DEEP AND EXTENSIVE
TIES TO THE CHINESE PARTY.
DOESN’T SURPRISE ME AT ALL.